Hello, and welcome back to another custard at
the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, Rawkode. Today
is Clustered Teams part two.
We have two great teams lined up. We
have a team from Talos and a team
from Red Hat.
Before we get started on the Kubernetes debugging
weirdness
madness, I'm not sure which one to use,
there's a little bit of housekeeping. So first
and foremost, please subscribe to the YouTube channel
and tick the bell. This will get you
alerts for all new episodes on Rawkode Live,
which means that you can come and learn
all of the weird tools and the cloud
native landscape together. Also, if you wanna chat
about Kubernetes, cloud native, and if and in
between, there is also a Discord server
that is available at rockode.chat.
And also, I wanna thank Teleport. Teleport have
been sponsoring Clustard, and it was the easiest
decision that I ever had to make because
we have been using Teleport since the very
first episode.
Today, we're using Teleport with some new, easier
mechanisms
to access our applications via private link, and
you'll see that just soon. If you wanna
support the show, please go check out Teleport.
You can do so at Rawkode.live/Teleport.
I would really appreciate it. Also, thank you
to Equinix Metal. They provide all of the
hardware that we use on Clustard, and you
can also use the code Rawkode for $200
to spin up your own bare metal stuff.
Alright. That is all the housekeeping and I
am happy to introduce our first team.
Hello, team Talos.
Hello.
Thank you
Excited or nervous. It's always a bit of
both. Right?
Yeah. Both. A little bit of both.
Alright. Well, could we start,
I guess, top right and then down to
Sean and along? Just a small introduction. Share
whatever you want, and then we'll get into
today's first cluster.
Sure.
You said starting from the top right? Yeah.
You, Andrew. Do we see the same oh,
okay. That's me. I don't know if we
see the same phrase.
Yeah. Exactly.
I'm Andrew Reinhardt. I'm the CTO of Talos
Systems, creator of Talos, longtime
container user, Go programmer for fun on the
side of doing operations SRE work.
I'll make it quick. I wanna get into
the action.
I'm Andre Smirnoff, developer at Telos Systems. So
working on Telos and projects around it, like
developing stuff, breaking clusters not because I want
to do that because I make bugs and
fixing them all the time.
Nice.
Hey, y'all. I'm Spencer.
I'm an engineer at Telus as well. Of
course, I mostly work on our cluster API
side of things.
And I'm also here as Andrew's stunt double
if needed. So
Hi. I'm Sean McCord. I am an engineer
at Red Hat. Oh, no. I'm sorry. At
Telos.
I've been building and breaking
distributed and fault tolerant
Linux based
distributed systems since the mid nineties.
Got in early on Kubernetes with CoreOS
and loving it here at Telus.
Awesome. Thank you very much all. And I
will also let you know that the Red
Hat team are in the chat saying that
they have been very bad today.
So
Yeah. I saw that. We we were debating
how bad we wanted to be. We ended
up being nice. Because, you know Well, you
know, there there's, like, very few rules as
you're now aware. Right? But one of the
rules is do not break Teleport because
if we can't access Teleport, we can't pair
to fix the cluster. Very boring.
Yeah. And what did Red Hat do? They
broke Teleport. So Nice.
Yes. They were Basically, there's only one rule.
Minus 10,000 points for Red Hat anyway.
Let's get my screen share up. Now there's
a few nice additions to our Teleport setup.
I wanna thank Ben at Teleport for helping
me with some of this new automation. But
you can see we have a nice shiny
URL.
You no longer have to type. This is
insecure into your browser. Nice start. I have
also exposed the clustered application. It is available
here on applications. So when you want me
to try and see if it is working,
just let me know, and we will hit
the link.
I am going to open our first session
on the control plane.
And if you could all do me a
favor, go to act active sessions and join
and type echo hello, echo hi, echo whatever
you wish.
Hopefully, can see everyone in here in the
next moment.
Alright. Looks like I got a couple of
you. I've got three names here. I'm expecting
to see
five.
Who have I got? Let's see.
Andrew and Spencer. Sean and Andre, I think
you opened your own session,
Or you're just not listening to me. I'm
not sure.
I'm just fighting with the CLI. I'll join
on. Alright. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. No worries. He's
just nice.
Alright. We've got a little bit of setup
that we have to do anyway. So well,
Spencer, Andrew, do me a favor. Export our
cube config, configure any aliases, and let's check
if we have a control plan.
Oh, where's my auto complete?
You can enable completion on kube control
if you wish.
Is Admin.com.
Admin Com.
We free to just go or what? Yeah.
Let's get some notes, man.
Let's see. Permission to know. Oh.
Let's check. And you've hit your first snag.
There we go.
I see we got a fourth. That means
we've got we've got one off. There we
go. They're all here. Was someone driving there,
or is that me?
Sorry. That was me. Go ahead.
Okay.
Make it plus x.
Yep.
I need my autocomplete stuff. I'm lost.
You didn't install fish while you're here too?
I can I can type if you want?
Oh. Okay. Nice.
Okay.
That's an interesting start.
I think we were a large group.
Think it's just a group. Okay.
I think they took away
Yeah. I'll send on change mode.
The chimotes to the chimote.
Yeah. Yeah.
And do an do an l s dash
l a on user bin.
Change mod for probably just bin change mod.
Oh, bother. You don't even have tab completion?
What is this? I don't. Yes. It's telling
me. But, hey. We'll make it work. If
you don't, I think that's probably because they've
changed that.
Yeah. Exactly. So just look at the whole
slash bin. Is there anything we should execute
a bot call?
Well, l s is obviously. Well,
l s is a built in. So let's
see.
No. L l there's a bin LS.
It's not a built raised, but that one
is built in. So, yeah, let's do
okay. Other I could scroll back.
Can we, like But for anyone who's not
familiar, green means executable. Right?
Yeah. Can we have to install something? I
mean, just to fix things.
Easy way. Yeah. You can do whatever you
want.
Yeah. What is this? Core utils?
Just remove or move it out of the
way and do an app. Oh, sorry. Go
ahead. Whoever was doing that. Go ahead. Oh,
I mean, I was just I'm not sure
what is Core utils?
I think it's core tilt.
Might be core dash. I you need a
force, but oh, yeah. You can't even do
that.
Beautiful. Nice. Oh.
So there's people in the chat saying this
is SE Linux. Using Schmalt. But these are
Ubuntu machines. Just FYI.
Apps are using Schmalt. That's the worst.
Yeah.
So
okay. Can I curl some Download the yeah?
Let's download the
Debian file, and maybe you can
can we download the Debian file?
Oh, look. That's there. Maybe it's already there.
We just need to reinstall it.
It looks like it's in the the cache.
If we can unpack the Debian file, that's
what I'm getting at.
The app cache.
That's a good idea.
Oh, interesting. I found a cool hack too.
I can try that
to execute things
We'll make it executable. The we're sorry directory
is where they have left hints if you
require them. Oh, okay. Oops. Sorry. We don't
wanna cheat yet.
No. Do we have this?
Where is this? Apparently, you can have SE
Linux on the bin to these days. I
had no idea. Thanks, Walid.
Where is looking for?
There is, like, a For LD? Yeah. No.
LD, like, a cool hack to run an
executable without marking it as executable.
But I don't know whether LLV Linux is
here on this.
Yeah.
Where is LBP? It should be in Lib
somewhere.
Yeah. Where it is.
Or Lib 64.
Okay. We have
okay. Here it is, I guess.
Can we
oops.
I did that.
As the as I have the inspector now.
How to paste here?
I have no idea. Can anyone paste that?
Copy and paste that.
What are we trying to do? Oh, the
name of it? Yeah. The name of that.
I can't. Okay. Yeah. I can't even select.
I got it. I can type I can
type the rest. Thank you. Because I can't
copy paste
in the web browser currently.
I
think at least we were able to run
it. Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. You are. Yeah. Nice.
So we need user bencher mode instead of
bencher mode. Yeah.
What it means
we need attributes. Let's check extended attributes. I
don't remember how to do that, but I
think that's the only
last dash what to see the attributes.
Oh.
You can use l s t r, but
they also remove the x from that if
you check. A
a
yes. What is a l s a t
t r. All one word. Yeah. That's command
s l s t t Okay.
Not like that. That's the command Sorry. Yeah.
L s a t t r.
No dash. Yes?
Yes. There we go. Okay. Oh, it did
work. I guess immutable. Right?
Yeah. Whatever it is.
It's not our my Strange.
Lord. So
we need to copy paste that LD Linux.
We need to copy paste that LD Linux,
I guess, once again, to execute There you
go. This. Okay. Yeah. Who knows what to
do next?
Is it Chatter,
Chamad.
Chatter, I guess. How to remove immutable.
Is it oh, I haven't used Minus equals
I?
That sounds familiar.
No.
What is it? I haven't wait. I wanna
say minus I.
Minus I.
It looks like minus I.
Okay. Let's see. We can that
now.
Okay.
We have. Oh,
Oh, that's fun. User.
That's a cool one, though. Mhmm. That was
like Using LDD LD.
Yeah. Thanks, Nicole. Gonna tell me. Okay. We
we are gonna have to install fish or
something. This this lack of
completion is
maddening.
Okay. Probably, it's same tree.
Same tree as the using the router. Some
other maybe?
Less adders on that bad boy.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Let let's fix Chatter
probably first. Yeah. It's mutable as well. Yeah.
So we need to fix Chatter itself. Right?
Yeah. Oh,
go ahead. So we need to You need
that l d Linux copied again?
I don't know. No. It worked Oh. At
least. Right? Cool. Nice. It looks like. Right?
So
dash
I.
Oh, I'm always pressing.
Okay. Do we have Yeah. I know. You
can load your batch now. Now it should
See if my now can
Yeah.
Do I have to do this on that
right now?
Nice.
What?
Give it the full path? Oh, is
well, kubectl is there. What is our path?
Was there.
Was there just a moment ago.
Nice. Is it actually kubectl?
Oh,
let's see what it what it is. Is
it Yeah. Let's see if it's binary or
not.
Might be a script.
Yeah. I
think they're promoting some product.
No. Okay. Let's different. I mean okay. Yeah.
Let's just curl it. I think let's get
Yeah. Square. We'll just get it from the
source.
Okay. Whoever can copy paste because yeah.
We really could've
you know, that's that's like we really could've
just skipped all of this, couldn't we have?
And that's cool.
Good too, man. Yeah. We did all that
just to just to get
kubectl
and kubectl itself is replaced. Yeah. Yeah.
I wonder if that's the only Change mod.
Again.
See, we would do it anyway. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Here we go. Alright. Get
nodes.
Okay. Alright. Let's move this back. Alright. Sorry.
Yeah. Okay.
Time 1646.
It's six minutes expired.
Oh, you're gonna have to load those completions.
That's gonna get really annoying.
Yeah. Yeah. How well, I don't know what
you're talking about.
You want me to type what I think
it is? Yes,
please. Let me fix this real quick.
There you go. Yeah. Which completions are you
I think bash
completions. Right? Bash dash completion, I think. Is
that what it is?
Let's see.
Fire as an argument. And then normally, you
would source it. Dash
oh,
that don't work.
Bash dash completions altogether,
all one or completion singular maybe.
Oh, that's roughly the command. If one of
you knows what it is Something like that.
Take over.
Something like this, Spencer? Oh, go ahead. Probably
need to install it.
I think it's just not enough.
Hang on. Sorry.
But, I mean, we we probably need to
fix this cert. Yeah. Just install fish. Yeah.
Who cares? Yeah. You can just install fish.
Go for it. Why not? Then
you're definitely gonna be the one driving, Andrew.
Yeah.
Did. Did. There. We never fixed echo. We
need to just do the chain chatter on
all of the files in bin and user
bin.
Open everything up.
I imagine it looks it looks a bit
of a wildcard.
Just do one star and the comment and
the chat from Waleed saying you could probably
source /etc/profile.c/completion.
Sorry.
I missed that.
Oh, that chatter. I don't know. You want
you want the the Chatter?
Yeah.
I
someone do it because I heard five people
talking. So who wants to do it? Who
has the idea? Do it. K.
Okay.
There we go. Yeah. I think it's alright.
Hello, fish.
There we go.
Okay. Cool.
Alright.
Does it feel more like home there?
Yes. A little bit. Yeah. A little bit.
Never look at the server. Certificate expired or
not valid yet. Yeah. Certificate expired ten minutes
ago. So Yeah. I think we need a
Is there the time right on this thread?
Yeah. It looks like I mean, it it's
right enough. Yeah. We could probably just alter
the time and cheat.
That will break teleport.
Oh, well, then let's not do that. Okay.
That's what we can do. Alright.
I have to generate the cert. These hard
Scoopy DM. Two beta d m. So that's
Spencer.
Oh, yeah. Alright.
I don't know. Let's let's
rebuild the cluster.
Yeah.
Oh, so know about it. Well yeah.
But kubadian doesn't need a command for this.
Kubadian certs, yeah, has a looks like renew.
Yeah.
Kubadian certs. Only renew just a single one
if you if you just Oh, what somebody
somebody has been using Yeah. Someone tried it.
Yeah.
Oh, I need the v I command, the
v I bindings.
Mode.
Oh, yeah. Just change the
clock back. Okay. So we could do that.
Yeah. That's what he was saying. You know,
the break telecode
or teleport. I mean, I so,
obviously So I don't think we wanna renew
the API server. We wanna renew the the
admin
cert or whatever Kubernetes calls the admin cert
or all yeah. Sure. Why not? I don't
know. But admin.com
looks like.
It's gonna be fun if we break it
even worse.
Yeah. Let's not break it before we know
it's broken.
Oh.
I cannot oh, right. We have the other
screen.
Pair reading configuration from the cluster.
Is that not successful?
Yeah. Because it's it relies on something like
EK access,
Yeah.
Right.
You're right with the all. If you run
the all, you should be able to bypass
that. All.
Now we need to restart things.
Yeah. Yeah.
Probably
Just kill the pods. Everything should be a
static pod except for Kubler. Right? I mean,
this is probably c r I c t
l and just kill the pods so that
they will be restarted by by the Kubelet.
I forget what's the socket
runtime endpoint. That's right.
CRI CTL,
and this is going to be
var
run
or is it var container b?
Sorry. Say that again, Andre?
No. I mean, just pods. Yeah. I mean,
just kill all of them and make kubel
restart them.
Well, they should be static. Right? Can't I
just move them out? You can move them
out, yeah, as well.
But I wonder why they are not ready,
though. But
Yeah.
We'll get x let's get API access first
maybe? Or
Yeah. So at least, yeah, resolve the
cert error. Well, let's be let's see what's
in here first so that I know I'm
copying.
We are halfway through.
Okay.
We don't even have the control player. Pressure.
Yeah. I know. Right?
You have been dealt a rough hand, I
must say.
ETCD,
though. Is that Yeah. Yeah. Can a directory
for it first.
Obviously,
you we were saying it would be cheating
to check the bash bash history, but, you
know, when fish is showing us the stuff
in front of you.
Well, it's their fault for not clearing it.
History dash c is your friend on. Yeah.
Well, this is a little strange. This move
is hanging. Yeah. It seems bad.
Yeah.
And I don't have access anymore. It is.
Anyone lose
access?
What? You don't have access? Oh, wait. Uh-oh.
Is Teleport running? Did
Teleport depend on something here?
Oh, wait. Ku VIP.
Oh, no.
Is that gonna remove the Well, Ku VIP
was not ready anyway.
We have lost our BGP advertisement. Nice.
But
the teleport was connecting to local host,
so it shouldn't have been using the VIP.
The BGP address is for the DNS name.
Can
we attach it to the packet after the
Equinix metal?
No. It's we can still SSH in. Somebody
can still SSH into that. Yeah. I can.
Yeah. Yeah.
Just as a point here, KubeVip was running,
API server was running, and that CD was
running. There were just two copies.
But,
yes, what we have done is killed our
so I'm guessing this is how
Red Hat killed the Telnet
or Tel Teleport,
whatever it is, to begin with, is they
killed the VIP if it's dependent on the
VIP.
Alright. So I am on the control plane.
Well, I've now learned a vital lesson. We
we can go through go in through the
backdoor and SSH and through the through the
worker and into the the problem is the
audience wouldn't be able to see that. They
can see me doing it right now. We're
good now. Yeah. We're good now. You wanna
go into Etsy Kubernetes PKI. That's where I
made a directory called what.
And then the kubectl needs to be put
into Etsy Kubernetes manifest. Like so?
Move one star. Yeah. Let me see. Yeah.
That's I don't know where you are, but
yes.
I think so. But
yeah. Okay. The static port manifesto back in
the directory.
Should
hopefully start. We broadcast our IP.
And then for all future episodes, I will
never use the EIP for teleport.
Yes.
Well, he just asking why do you need
a a VIT and a single API control
plan?
I don't. Probably
a fair question.
It's just a cheap and easy way of
doing the BGP advertisement.
Exactly.
Alright. So back.
Do I need to, like, leave and come
back to the session? My queue has not
started yet.
Oh, wow. I bet you it won't start
because
Red Hat broke it. Now we can't start
stuff.
Well, I mean, that was their goal. Right?
They wanted the breakings,
maybe the pods just aren't starting because of
whatever Red Hat did.
And now
yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So that means we
have to go now. We have remote happens,
essentially.
Alright. Well, the cubelet looks like it's and
ears on the ground.
I'm
not supposed to be playing, but I will
type whatever you want.
I don't know what you think. Let's
look see right CTL ports. Right? I mean,
just to see what's
yeah. This one.
Yes.
Doesn't look it's picking up these
at all. Yeah. We need to look at
the log now.
Yeah. So We should be running static pods.
Yep.
Should always be doing that.
Yeah. Exactly.
Unless it has some command line options telling
it to look in a different place.
We know that was running, though, of course,
because when we moved them out Right. Yeah.
Was.
Yeah. Still, it's worth checking the command line
arguments to the kubelet. Kubelet kubelet
conf, maybe.
Yeah.
Oh, it was in that directory.
It yeah. Yeah.
What'd wanna see?
Just look for manifest if it's there.
Yeah. Yeah. Static bot bot. Yeah. Did
we
I don't know. Let's try turning it off
and back on again.
Yep.
Node not found. That's No. This this is
normal. Yeah. That's it. Yeah. I think yeah.
Right. You're I think you may be back
in the game now. It's it's good. Yeah.
There you go. Yeah. We're back. Teleport's back.
Nice.
I got disconnected, but I got it. I'm
gonna allocate you a little bit of extra
time because of that. I was I
I was afraid we were being too mean.
We were way
too nice.
Alright. All the nos are good. Alright. Where
were we? Remember
to join my session, please.
I think I joined it. The the new
one. Right?
Oh, there's a new session.
Oh, there's a new one too. Sorry. Okay.
Yeah. I think the old one might be
on the end of the Okay.
A few seconds ago, first.
Oh, yeah. There's two. Alright. I can see
who's joining. No. There we go. Yeah. Oh,
straight into fish.
Yeah. That's
Alright. There we are. Cool. Yeah. He's doing
all of that. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Good own thing.
Alright.
Looks good. Cool.
Yeah. There's a there's a Wonderland namespace with
a rabbit hole that's not like the look
of.
Oops.
Those are rough. Everything.
Cool.
What does it look like when we hit
the service? Is there anything where
Let's check the application.
Yeah. Can we check the application? Alright. The
application. That's it. Yep. So let's hit applications.
We hit clustered and
Failed to connect the database.
Alright. Alright. So Okay.
Have postcard.
Going by, so I guess the broke.
So
Let's check the network policies or whatever else.
Yeah.
There's endpoints.
Yeah. Let's make sure that endpoint
actually matches up with the clustered pod, and
they're not Yeah. Pointing us to the wrong
place somehow.
Yep.
What is it called? Is it called clustered?
Is that it?
Just
The postcard service is the one that's supposed
to communicate right now. Oh, right. Right. Right.
Yeah.
There's been some keen observations in the chat
if any one of you wants to take
a quick look.
Selector is Postgres.
That looks good to me.
Yep.
Sorry. What was the chat?
Are
there any
So no one in the chat that naughty
noticed some weird DNS configuration in the.
Okay.
Maybe we look at
No. Network policies. Okay. That's a with that
maybe.
Yeah. That's probably good. Mean, these are in
the default namespace.
But either way, let's go take a look
at that Keyblet. That's that was sounds interesting.
In the Keyblet config The config. They were
saying they found they saw something somebody saw.
That was Barliv from it?
Yeah. I think so. Yeah.
Oh, I didn't realize this. Okay. I see
the chat now. I was like, How do
I see this?
I see DNS.
That's the only mention of it.
It looks looks nice.
Nice.
The resolve conf
was the one that Noel pointed at.
That looks fine.
It's a system system needs. So oh,
unless that's an extra e on the end
of resolve.
Doanls-lon@cresolve.com.
That should be a link to the run.
Oh, it's not a link to the run.
Okay.
So go to slash run slash system b
slash
resolve.
Cap that.
Is that different?
I don't think so.
Well, maybe it was, actually.
No. Looks the same. I'm gonna email. So
Yeah. So that's fine
or should be fine, assuming we can say
ping Google dot com and we are resolving.
Well, we have a duration. Oh, but but
but we're not resolving to
the well, we don't know that.
In other words, are they overriding the core
DNS?
Can
we get into the application port and try
to But, yeah, let's let's take a look
at Like, yeah, ping the endpoint and,
like, debug from that.
Yeah. We should be able to you should
be able to exactly on the bash on
that. I'm gonna
Okay.
How do we
k.
I didn't know you could do that to
a deployment. That's nice. Oh, yeah. Yeah. That's
so great. How to use the So nice.
So
nope.
Really nice.
Useful.
Just try to ping it. Yeah.
That's what we tell us more
about it.
Alright. DNS resolve. Action. Mhmm. Yeah. And I
think the IP is But is it to
the right? It's correct.
Alright. So it's just being locked. Do we
have a route
IP route?
0220.
Maybe. Could be right.
Well, it's isn't it weird?
No network policies. So
so ping Kubernetes.
Yep.
So
we can't even get to the API server
in that
subnet. But, also, interestingly,
the Kubernetes
service IP is different from
the I wonder if they switched the service
IPs.
Take a look at the silicon configs.
Yep.
That service IP looks okay to me. Were
you expecting to see something different?
Well, I don't know. I don't know what
the service subnet is.
It may be fine depending on the scope.
What are we looking for? Slider here? Or
yeah. Cluster pool slider
is 100008.
Oh, what is there? Is it? Yeah. Yeah.
So it's fine.
Yeah.
Let's look at the nodes. Maybe. We'll have
a suggestion to check the Cilium network policy
whether it's blocked on the
We That's a good idea. Oh, yes. Cilium
has its own Cilium Yeah. Policies
that are not in standard
network policies. Yep.
Cilium network policies.
Yeah. And also Cilium plus UI. I do
understand
why they did that. Everybody seems to have
to their have their own network policies, but
it's still to do.
Okay.
Yeah. This is one hell of a
No.
It's like CMP,
I think, but okay.
And, yeah, there's
there's just Cilium network policies as well. Just
Cilium network policies.
Yeah. Postgres. Yeah. Yeah.
Can we just delete them? Delete them. Postgres.
Yeah. Just delete them. Nothing bad ever came
from deleting a policy.
Yeah. Actually,
once.
Just do dash a with delete, and that's
it.
Even Then the no. Dash dash Yeah. No.
Yeah. But okay. That's what You're fine for
that.
Alright. Can we check the whatchamacallit
now?
Yep. Is the egress, the Postgres one something
we should think about too?
I don't know. I mean, probably, but
that's in cube system.
That's,
I don't know. I mean, judging by the
name. Who knows?
Connection to database. Delete that anyway. Yeah. Delete
it. Yeah. We should delete it anyway. They
were obviously not at the same.
And
yeah.
I'm
just gonna do the way I know. Dash
dash Yeah. Just the dash oh.
Yeah. I think you're just missing the namespace.
That's not shit. It is the
scrolling keeps messing up.
Yeah. I don't know what's going on.
It's probably a mismatch in the resolutions, and
Teleport is not It's it's not dash dash.
It's dash dash.
Yeah. Dash dash. That's right. Yeah. That's the
easiest.
Dash dash.
Dash dash Dash dash.
There we go.
Can we try it now?
Build to connect the database.
Alright. Well, we got that out of the
way. So default policy.
And do we have a default policy in
Saleem?
Should we check whether ping is working now?
What?
Yeah. Sure.
Kubernetes.
No. No. And why this didn't work? Because
this I mean, I haven't looked into these
policies by judging by the name. It should
block access only. Okay. So Yeah. Let's check
the check the Cilium config and make sure
the default policy is not enabled. Just
How can we configure
my session?
You'll want namespace
as
You don't have the plug in for config
config
and yeah.
What are looking for?
Pipe
grip
policy.
Should we check the hints if we're running
out of time? You have ten minutes with
the additional time because of the teleport break.
I'm not giving up, but just
Enable policy by default. So let's turn that
off.
Set that to never.
Okay. I'm not familiar with the enable policy
default. Do you wanna does anyone know what
that is? Yeah.
So we can add, of course, network policies,
but you can also assign a default to
require the network policy.
And so if we are requiring a network
policy and there is no network policy, the
default is to block.
Uh-huh. Never?
Yeah. Never.
And will that require It's a good catch
all for for making sure that you don't
accidentally
expose anything on the network.
I guess we're gonna have to do a
rollout or a delete. Yeah.
Maybe don't dash dash all that.
No.
Right.
Please.
Let's kill teleports once again and get more
time.
Clock, please. Right?
Alright.
Check it now. K.
Cilium is not yet ready. It worked. Oh.
Hey. Hey.
So the objective is to right now? So
is this v one, I guess? Just so
we could go edit our deployment right now.
What else are we gonna encounter for v
two? Yeah. But Yeah. True. We'll see. Let's
try to edit our deployment real fast.
Yes. So let's just edit it. Is that
all we do? Uh-huh. For everyone that's not
familiar, the objective is to upgrade the clustered
application from v one to v two and
then see v two working. I should be
doing my happy dance.
Only deployment.
Deployment.
That Spanish?
Yeah. Deployment. Edit.
Just push push enter, and it works. You
have only one. Yeah. I know. Yeah. It's
just a reset. It's medium
OCD and pedantic.
You can search. Search for image.
Yep.
Why is there that? So much space. You
have seven minutes to exit them. There you
go. Go, Alex.
Alright.
Give me a second. It's running.
That's my sad face. Let me refresh again.
Are you sure we have v two?
Well, it's I mean, the old one is
not yet done or according to the last
can do another GitPods?
Somebody?
Yeah. It should be up now.
But let's let's check the Yep. There we
go. Again.
You got the dance. Well,
that's alright.
With one minute to spare.
Well, you you had six minutes to spare
because of the extra time. So Oh, okay.
Okay. You swear you smashed it. Well done.
Lots of claps coming in in the chat
there.
Damn. They did not make that easy.
No. They did not. No. They did not.
That was fun. Well Mhmm. It's tedious. That
was a lot of fun. See, that's what
that's what we wanted to avoid in ours
is eliminate the tedious that nobody We could've
But we No. We had to go through
the tedious.
But it was I could take ten minutes
by just downloading Kubez ETL.
It was entertaining, and you explained the processes
and what you were doing very well. I
think we got a lot of learnings out
of that. So
That was very cool. Yeah. That was Yeah.
Now I know what to do. A lot
when mod is not executable. Yeah. Yeah. Who
knew that trick. Right?
What? Alright. Well, thank interview question. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks. Thanks, Red Hat folks. Thank you. Alright.
Well, thank you very much, Talos. I'm gonna
say you may now
exit the call. I will invite Red Hat
to join us, and we'll see what tricks
you have in store for them. So thank
you again. It was an absolute pleasure. Alrighty.
You. And good luck, Red Hat.
Alright. We'll jump over here. And while we
are waiting,
I will just quickly say thank you to
our sponsor,
Teleport.
It's been a pleasure working with them. I
like all the extra things that they've helped
me configure for the environment here as well.
It's really nice been able to just pop
open our secret clustered application through the teleport
interface and check if it's working.
Red Hat, hopefully you are all joining our
session right now.
I don't see anyone yet, which means I
just have to talk.
Although the latency isn't too bad, there was
lots of great chat there, great advice. Although
Noel, come on Noel. The DNS,
you send them on a wild ride.
And I oh, we got a comment from
Candice from team Red Hat saying that it's
actually one of their interview questions. There you
go.
Oh, team Red Hat are here. Let's pop
over. Who do we have? We have Christophe.
We've got James.
There's Candice.
And fashionably late,
g f.
Alright.
Let me get your names on the screen.
Meet I gotta meet the stream.
Oh, yeah. Don't have the streamer running in
the background. Here's our crew.
Yeah.
You didn't give them access to and
removed executable status from KubeControl, which was wasn't
even KubeControl anyway. Come on. So
we did a lot more than that. Actually,
them circumventing the Cilium network policy was amazing.
We did not plan That was brilliant.
If they would have looked at the image
that was running Cilium, it actually was running,
our custom operator that would re recreate
the,
the network policies over and over and over,
so they couldn't delete them. And they couldn't
update them either.
But, I mean, turning off all the Cilium
network policies was
beautiful.
Around that problem.
Yep.
Well, there you go. The objectives are clear.
You just need to be able to upgrade
the application and browse to it. So good
job, Talos.
But now it's your turn.
I'm excited. Alright. So I'm gonna pull up
Talos.cluster.live.
Oh, sorry.
Introductions.
Can we start with you, Christophe, and just
work your way around? Can you please all
say hello and tell us a little bit
about yourself?
Sure thing. Hello, everyone. My name is Christophe
Lecker. I
am a principal engineer with Red Hat.
I also am involved in the Kubernetes upstream
project.
I'm a member of the steering committee, and
I'm a technical lead for,
the contributor Experience Sick.
Either one of you, Jiffy, James, go for
it. Whoever whatever direction you just wanna look
around.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
I guess, hello. I'm James Harrington.
I'm a principal engineer
on the, OpenShift dedicated team here at Red
Hat.
I'm also a a team lead alongside,
Christophe and
I'm part of the team with Candice and
and Jeff.
Hey, everyone. I'm Candice. I am a senior
software engineer on the team with Christophe, James,
and Jeff here.
I'm also one of the region leads for
our North American region here at Red Hat.
Hello. Hello. My name is Jeffrey Sika. I'm
a principal engineer at Red Hat. I am
the team lead for the CI team that
works on CI for OpenShift dedicated.
I'm also kind of all over the place
in the Kubernetes community and
typically posting like, geese memes and random gifts
on Twitter. So
just see me around.
Alright. Thank you all, and thank you for
joining me.
I'm going to hand over now your first
control plane node. So hopefully you all have
access to what we need. I have opened
a session on the control plane.
If you can all join, we'll keep an
eye on who is here and then we'll
get this configured
for our debugging.
Yeah. I can see one already. Oh, five.
There we go. Everyone is here.
It's always fun seeing what hello message people
like to choose to make sure the echo
is working.
Sup? Good day. Well, hi and hi. There
we go. Please configure your cube config and
good
luck.
No
control plan. Who'd have thunk it?
By the way, did we decide who's driving?
We did not. Half
the call is gonna be who's driving.
James
said he would drive.
James, you're driving.
Lucky me. Alright. Let's go.
Let's see. What do we got here? The
connection to the server is refused. Did you
specify the right port? I would hope so.
Let's have a look. Where is this QConfig?
So
First thing that opt
first thing that I would check is look
at the IP address for this post and
make sure that they line up.
Do you want to
create that alias, by the way? We can.
I know that
Which alias?
Alias. So you can the Yeah. Or.
Does someone wanna do that for me?
For everyone laughing in the chat, this is
a problem.
Did I do that already?
So what is OC?
OC is the OpenShift flavor,
like, the OpenShift client for
interacting with a cluster via the CLI. So
Got it.
There we go. Today, I learned. I
cannot reprogram my brain to use anything but
OXY.
So
these are different.
Yep. So one of them will be the
Elastic IP
rather than the machine.
Okay. I'll start with this one and
use two QTPL.
Okay. So if.
So this looks like If you look on
the look back, you should see the BGP
address.
Looking for a I see a bunch of
I p v six stuff.
Is this this one here?
The local address? Is that what I'm looking
for?
If you Do mind if I type?
Yeah. Go for it.
Oh,
old school. Sorry.
So, yep, that is the one on low
here as our BGP address, which I think
was correct on the cube config.
So am I putting that one back?
Yeah. I wish. Yep.
No worries.
Okay.
So the next thing that I would look
at is,
did they change the port that the API
server is listening to? Also, please don't let
me be the only one talking.
Alright. Let's have a look. I always feel
bad.
Man, OC undone. Alias. OC is alias for
you, James.
Thanks.
You're always so nice to me.
We try. Okay.
Alright. Kube server API
IP address to get that. I'm going to
look at
cryo,
maybe. What am I gonna look at here?
There's I checked with flags, kubelet's running with
Okay. To start with. Like, I just do
a p s a u x and grep
per cube.
Yeah.
So don't kill
Don't kill CubeVip. Got it.
So is it running on that local address?
Is that what's going on here?
The API server is just not running. It's
a node IP. Okay. The the the API
server is not running at all. Like, there's
Cubelet. There's the controller manager.
There's a scheduler. There's etcd.
Yeah.
But I don't see the API server at
all. That's usually a problem. Just in my
experience, I thought I'd share that with you.
That might be an issue. Thank you. You're
right.
Alright. So how do we get this thing
running?
I'm assuming that maybe the manifest is missing.
It's there.
What's in there?
Alright. And we need to look at some
logs here, probably.
I checked next the Ubuntu
service status,
Like Yeah. Service
space dash dash status dash all.
Do you like this?
Oh, sorry. Status dash all.
I don't know what the recommend is saying.
Let me drive for a sec. Go for
it.
K. Not listed in there.
What were you looking for there? Sorry.
I'm seeing how the the API servers like
this configured to It's a static pod manifest.
So it's run by the cubelet, which is
healthy and running.
Maybe we can look at the cubelet logs,
Christophe, and see if they've got any
errors in there. Maybe it can't be passed
or something because it was in the manifest
folder.
K. Go for it.
I don't know where the cubit logs go.
The cubit logs are available over journal control,
and the API server logs will be in
bar log containers
if you wanna look.
Here we go. So
trying to read this.
There are so many errors. Oh my god.
There are a lot of errors. Yeah. It
fail it definitely failed to start container, cube
API server.
Network not ready,
but that would probably be because the a
p yeah. So API server is definitely plug
in not not initialized.
But it needs the API server for that.
Yeah.
Where is the API error Crash loop back
off?
Yeah. Crash loop back off coming from
the API server.
Error syncing pod skipping.
Okay.
So
Can I drive for a minute?
Go for it.
Are both of you done looking at the
logs? Yeah.
Candice?
Yeah. So,
the CNI issues, know, that's usually in something
like,
at the CNI,
net.d
maybe.
I don't know if that's where we wanna
start.
What I want to do I already forgot
because I was waiting. It
had to do with the manifest.
Wanted to like, verify that the image was
correct
first.
And, like, maybe they put in an image
that just
didn't make sense,
and that would cause it to crash.
That all looks good.
We got a suggestion in the chat to
collect the must gather.
Thanks. I think you really need to look
at the API server logs.
Like,
because you don't know why it's not running
right now.
Right?
Correct.
But API server log?
Oh, yes. So the kubelet will have attempted
to start it. I assume it's run and
we probably have logs and bar logs containers.
Mean, I I I would check.
You'll probably find there's a cube dash API
server. Yep.
Okay. So that Okay. So that's now to
It can't connect to that's Saturday. Right?
Yeah.
But NCD was running?
It looked like it from when
we were running PS.
Is the etcd port changed? Like, there's some
things there that I wasn't looking at.
no. 2379.
Oh, crap. Sorry.
Natalia's team are reminding you there are hints
if you want them.
Did we see etcd on PS, though? I
don't remember seeing it.
We only looked for q. Read that.
No etcd.
Okay.
That'll do it.
We should check the journal logs for etcd,
try and see if there's any errors in
there for that.
Wasn't the etcd also a static pod?
Correct.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
No leader.
Well Is it configured for when
it's not
we're not in configuration?
It's rough.
Alright. I'm tagging someone else in because I
have no idea how to look that up.
What's that?
We should probably look at the NCD configuration.
What's in the the static pod manifesting?
NCD is one of those things I keep
saying I'm gonna get better with debugging, but
I am terrible
at that. So
I'll need some help
to figure out how to check if this
is configured for It's also saying that the
obviously, the health endpoint wasn't working in that
log. Right?
So
start up pro
local host
2 3 8 1 for the health check.
Is that right? Should that be zero?
I think that port is okay. About with
ETCD.
I do think that port is okay for
the health check.
Okay. I think.
Just trying to look quickly what we can
do with etcd here.
So the
listen client URLs
kill the second one out of there.
Listen client URLs. Where are you seeing that?
Wait.
Actually, one sec.
No. Kill the first one. A loopback.
Yeah. I think that's a good shot.
Yeah. Keep keep the private IP one, but
kill the loopback out of listen client URLs.
In this
where is it?
Yeah. Up. It's in it's in the up,
up. It's in the, the command line flags.
So there's one listen dash client dash URLs.
Kill the loop back off of that. Keep
the private IP address.
I guess what you're thinking there is that
the existence of that second IP address is
putting it into an HAMode, which doesn't exist.
Right?
Yeah.
This one? That look good? Yep. Yep. Yep.
Alright.
Now
You should have the logs in this directory.
I would just do it. Yeah.
Let's have a look.
Scheduler API.
There we go. There it is.
Looks healthy. Hey. Yep. Ready.
Is the API server running now?
Still refused.
Will that be still changed? The API server
logs next.
Yeah.
Might be a layered issue.
Or actually, there is a yeah. Yeah. Kube
API server tiles control point one.
Oh,
let's see. Loop back address.
Still can't connect to SCD.
What if we change that to the private
IP as well?
Yep.
Kube
API server.
137.
Alright. Anything else in here?
No.
No. That looks good.
That fail will probably get rotated. You might
wanna
Yeah.
It's a good call. Yeah. Because you all
broke teleport, you've only got fifteen seconds left.
Good luck.
Yes.
They're the only one I think.
That should be at least a new one.
Right?
Well, the thing is the logs are still
showing local
host.
Do I need to kill this container? Which
it might it might just be the the
crash loop back off. Like, it might be
it might not have restarted the container yet.
No. No. No. Put a new address.
Okay. Yep.
Still not happy.
Happy Erbil. Right?
I mean, it
No. Maybe not.
NC might be available.
Netcat.
It is. I have no idea how to
use Netcat off the top of syntax.
I've added dash z to the start.
K.
A z.
Oh, sorry. That's sorry. And
it's a space, not a cool one. So
same syntaxes.
So spaces that are cool. Yeah. And
then echo the status, I think that
yeah. It's okay. Okay. So that's working.
Okay.
Let's have a look at running. The port
is open.
Sending new addresses
to
Looks like that file got rotated.
Same thing. Okay.
So
it's a decent
so, like, a whoops.
I just lost my screen. There you go.
Was the ETCD still is it happy?
I have I have
Yeah. Go back to the ETCD
logs.
Yeah. Okay. I think it is happy.
Oh, no. It's still throwing no leader.
K.
Health error, no leader.
You wanna double check the manifest again?
Yep.
Advertise client URLs. Is that the right port?
Client URLs.
Yeah. But why would we so
should we even be
is on local host. Does that need to
be changed?
No. That should be okay.
Should we even be
have the
okay. My brain. Should we even have peers
Yes. Set up? Okay.
Is
that city control available?
I
always use a cheat sheet, but I'm gonna
grab it
because nobody in Kubernetes.
But you will have to install it to
the client if you wanna throw that into
the thing just there.
No, we got it.
Oh, that means that someone has definitely been
playing with it.
There you go. SCD is now configured. You
should be able to speak at CD, but
obviously it's got a bit of a issue
at the moment.
Do we need?
Connection refused. I mean, it's not, like, IP
tables or something like that. Right? Well Well,
hold on. Should should we have
okay. Before in the advertised peers,
we deleted the local host. Should we have
instead deleted the private IP?
It's looking that way. Yeah. We can we
can check that and push it back towards
using the just the loopback.
This
Is this not listening on local host?
Nope. No. It's not.
Is that the issue?
It might be. Yeah. Let's let's edit the
etcd manifest to swap out back to the
local, the loopback as opposed to private IP,
and then we also need to do the
same for the Kube API server.
Yep.
So
etcd.
Listen client.
And the listen peer, same thing.
No.
It it
you'd it doesn't have any peers.
So I'd say that's fine. You might need
to change the advertised client URLs.
Yeah.
This is mean. I don't know which one
of these it should be.
We deserve everything that we're getting right now.
Oh, we were nice.
There's also an annotation.
Okay. Yeah. I see. Yep.
Alright. You have twenty minutes left.
And remember, there are hints if needed.
Yep. Under pressure.
Alright.
So that'll probably take a second while that's
booting.
We need to update the API server.
Yeah. Manifest.
At least I got auto complete. That could've
been
that was that was me. I'm sorry for
that one. That was Candice.
Yeah. That was before sorry. Harsh.
Yep. There you go.
Yep.
Okay.
Now let's
give it a hot minute.
Until the
I mean, you should be able to check
if it's a d is healthy just now
while you wait on the API server.
Now that it's the d c t l
is configured. You should be able to just
do a it's the control
Status. Status. Yeah. I think.
I don't
I'm maybe It's the control cluster health. Like
this one word?
Or dash Oh, sorry. Endpoint
health. Endpoint health. Endpoint space health.
No. Can't connect on local host.
Check the etcd logs. Like, did it boot
properly? I love that error message. Retrying of
unary invoker failed.
It's good to have etcd. Nobody?
Nobody.
Yeah.
Let's have a look here.
Could not connect to
checking
for PR,
and it's got this
IP.
Do we miss something somewhere? Delete delete that
flag.
Like, I'd I'd edit the Etsy config and
just delete that flag.
K.
So can I ask for something out? Like,
the way that you spend up Etsy d
on these machines is, it doesn't really care
if there appears or not upfront.
So there's probably something and say it's data
directory that tells it where the peers are
rather than modifying the flags at all.
So Where is the bar libetti.
Thank you.
Not bad.
Alright. I'm officially running out of ideas here.
I've
got an idea.
Yeah.
Where's the hint?
Talos team, if you're still watching, let us
know where the hints are.
Can you try NCT control member list?
I guess not. Okay.
So
I was gonna do a a find across
the file system for that IP it's trying
to
to connect to and try and service the
file that it's in.
Apparently, there is a hint dash one file.
In where at?
Root. Where, Talos? Come on.
Slash route.
Oh, yeah. They're saying slash route. I think
they've maybe
it is not in the control plan. That
would be silly, though.
I don't know how long this is gonna
take.
Alright. Let me check the worker notes just
in case.
Alright. I don't mean to worry you, but
SSH is not working on the work or
not.
Andrew from the team is saying a member
list would have worked if we hadn't restarted
at CP.
Hello?
Alright. I don't know what I'm doing here.
And they're telling me to check the workers,
which I cannot get access to.
So what I'm hearing is Red Hat has
broken,
Teleport twice today.
Doing well.
And they're breaking up in your control plan.
Like, is that proper
oh, that's okay. Yeah. It's just the workers
aren't working.
Alright. I will SSH on to the workers
manually,
see if I can find you the hint.
Oops. I've now broken everything.
Okay.
So
is it worth taking a look back at
this?
We're sure you'll find the answer just like
that.
Alright. If you just wanna pay attention to
the broadcast here, we do have MOTD and
we have HENTS.
You just want HENTS one then? HENTS one.
Quorum,
I don't
okay. So Latin? In insufficient quorum.
Yeah.
Is that a hen or a ton? I'm
not sure.
That's
Probably a little bit of both.
So we Can't I can't say we don't
deserve it, though.
No. I'm fine being stumped. At this point,
we know that there's something wrong with the
etcetera d, like, how it's configured. It is
trying to
when we when we reconfigured it to listen
to loop back, did we check that it's
actually able to listen to loop back and
where we can connect on it?
Yeah. But I I think the problem is
they've added a second member at one point,
and now the cluster expects to find quorum
and it can.
Yeah.
So
maybe we should be googling how to go
from an HATD
to a
single egg.
Already doing it. Or we can fire hands
two up. I don't know if that'll help
or not, but then,
yeah, I'm stumped. That's is.
It's harsh.
Oh, so
removing a failed SCD node, it looks like
there's, like, a flag for SCDCTL.
I think you and I just found the
same thing.
Capital c or something?
What was that host?
Forget the log again.
It may have rotated again.
Oh, yep.
I'm also not in the right directory. That
that won't help.
So if we go in here, sale the
the latest log,
which is going to be
this one.
Yeah. I think you wanna remove that member
A5E7C240BB16.
Oh, yeah. Probably should use the ID.
Yeah.
Yep. ID.
Alright. So
it's at c d c t
go ahead.
Was just I was gonna say the same
thing. You are at c d c t
l
member space remove.
Like so?
Yep.
Silence Oak.
Hold on. Hold on. I think I can
help a little bit.
Let me make this a more pasteable
fashion.
Keyboard,
hard to type.
We have ten minutes.
Yep.
Where is Chrome? Where is Chrome?
So that's how you remove it,
a member if it's completely lost quorum.
We need
So all that serif stuff is already configured.
So you can probably just add the dash
capital c.
Well, the one so the one thing that
we need is we need that member ID
again.
I think I've
You need the surviving host IP address. Right?
Which is Which is
You can use 127001.
Right?
Yeah. Just on the loop back?
Let's try it.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure I severely messed up the
terminal. Sorry about that.
Yeah. You kinda did, but, you know, it'll
Yeah. That I'll take that one.
Who's typing?
I am I am typing. I swear.
But I need
tail
to be I just need one of them.
Copy.
Member remove.
There's a
do you wanna type reset to fix the
terminal?
Thanks, Jason.
I think we're ready for hit number two,
actually.
Unknown shorthand flag.
Do we just need dash dash endpoints there?
Yeah.
Oh, did I miss that? I think Candice
is right. I don't think that dash c.
I think that might be either
an older version or newer version.
Looks like endpoints is the same thing.
Thanks, Candice. It could be an s t
d two to three different.
It did a thing.
An angry thing. Conflicting environment variable is shadowed
by corresponding
Oh. Yeah. We already have the endpoints configured
in the environment from that cheat sheet that
we copy and pasted.
So that member removed should maybe be working,
but it isn't.
Is there a force flag?
Dash dash kill with fire maybe?
If only.
So according to the chat, we already figured
out hint number two. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you mind if I look at the
help on this?
Alright. We got a you wanna see hint
three?
I think so. Sure.
There's a snapshot saved at var slash at
c d dot d g.
Oh, that was nice. That's that's mean.
Okay.
We can we can restore time.
Yep. Etcdctl
snapshot restore.
Where is it?
Slash VAR.
There you go.
Is that the only way to recover from
a highly available STD to a single node
is a snapshot?
I'm not 100%
sure.
Member list.
You may have to restart
NCD.
Sure.
Okay. I'd probably play it safe and remove
the static pod manifest to the restore and
then bring it back in.
Are saying there is a way to do
it without the restore. Maybe they can share
that with us in the chat, and we'll
share it with the share it with the
audience. That's a tough one.
Alright. It's not running. Looks good.
I would run that restore again before you
move it back just in case. Oh, glad
you.
Boom.
Is it?
Maybe you can just start it. No problem.
Maybe maybe the restores is done and happy.
I'm not sure.
Let's see.
Fingers crossed.
But I'm assuming if there was one component
that Talos were gonna mess with, you were
really hoping it wasn't gonna be entity.
That CD is hard.
As the
APIs that we're connecting now, is the at
CD log still showing the the issue?
Well, you'll you'll wanna make sure you can
run a member list on that SAT. We
need to know that's
somewhat healthy. We need to we need to
specify the data directory
when we restore it, when it's off.
There you go.
I think the data there will be
a varlib
etcd and then the snapshot fail at the
end.
I'm gonna go out in eleven. So let's
delete and
then do the restore.
Are we feeling brave?
I'll do it. Let's do it.
Oh, I think did we overwrite the snapshot
with the restore?
Restore. No? That seems to have worked. Alright.
And fingers crossed. Come on,
We believe in you.
Anyone have a hard spot? Are you okay
to go for another five to ten?
Okay. We've got a members list. If we
have a members list, I'm happy to give
you a a little bit more time if
as long as no one has to leave.
I have to leave in an hour and
a half, so I got plenty of Alright.
I'll see. I'll sell in. Right. Okay. We
need we need to okay. Okay. Now we
need to make sure that we are talking
to the right SCD service. I don't know
if we updated the cube API servers config
to talk to local host. I forget. That
was years ago.
It was years ago. Yeah. That'd be the
next thing I'd check.
Alright. What are we checking? K. We did.
The NCD server's line. Yeah.
Okay.
Yep.
The only other thing is
NCD is happy.
Is everything in that config file okay?
Let's see if the API server's up now.
Like, is is there something else in the
etch in the API server logs?
API server is up. So let's look at
the logs now.
Logs are in bar log.
Containers. Containers.
Container. Yep.
It's not erroring.
It's not error. Notes.
So on your HCT static manifest, the advertised
address is the I P V 4 address,
I believe.
Even though it listens on 127, I think
it advertises us another one. I don't know
if that matters.
Alright.
Well, this is the external address of the
API server as opposed to it connecting to
FCD.
So that should be fine. Try get notes
now that it's up and running.
Oh. There we go. K. We're closer.
Pods.
One node. So Talos worker two is not
ready.
Cilium is restarting like mad, but that was
probably because of the API server.
So
TELUS worker What TELUS worker two might actually
recover on its own because of psyllium recovery.
Perhaps.
What's the,
what's the status of the actual application?
Let's check. Are we getting it are we
getting an error from the application itself?
I'm assuming so.
Oh, it's loading. It's working.
And now your mission is to upgrade it.
Oh, boy.
Alright. I'm concerned.
As we are. As are we all.
Alright, Al.
Is it deployment?
Yeah. Deployment in the default namespace called clustered.
It seemed a bit easy.
I'm scared. It's exactly what I'm concerned.
I mean, STD problems are not easy.
No. True. No. And we did we are
we are five minutes over.
Yeah. They were they were much kinder than
we were.
So it's either not pulling or still pulling
an image.
So did I read the image name right
on that deployment? It was, like, g h
c r or something like that. Yep. It
looked okay.
Well, that's not ideal.
Nope.
So is the I thought you said you
were pretty nice.
Okay. So whatever is wrong with Talos worker
two is actually causing this.
Yeah.
What are the
well, does it need to schedule on TAL
Server two? Is it on TAL Server two
right now?
Is there a node selected on here somewhere?
You can just add node name
to bypass the scheduler.
That look great?
Yeah. I think so. That's a hard way.
It work.
Ending.
Well, if worker two is not ready, that's
never gonna schedule.
Wait. If worker two's. Is there is there
a taint or something on node one that's
preventing it from scheduling?
No. It did schedule on node one, but
we got problems setting up a sandbox because
it's got networking CNA issues.
And I don't think node two is actually
ready, which means it won't be able to
schedule on it. Schedule there. Yeah.
Celine is up and running on Celine is
up. False.
Is not up and running on this node.
Yeah. I'm sure when you ran get nodes,
it said worker two was not ready. Right?
Yes.
Have you described the note? Do we get
a message?
So
I didn't see any errors. I mean, it
could just be tinted.
Oh my god. Is it really just that?
Alright. Or you can look at hint four.
Is
try this one out.
Yeah. It's not it's not cool enough. Mind
if I drive for a sec? Go.
Is Google not running on that node?
Because it says Kubo has stopped posting node
status.
This space?
No. Look. It so in Talos worker one,
it did start kubelet after it had everything.
And you if you look at ours, it
doesn't start kubelet.
K. So kubelet's not running.
David, can you open a session on worker
two?
Indeed.
I would love to do it through Teleport,
but I don't know what Talos have done.
I
have a session open in the work or
two. Do you want me to just start
the Kubelet?
Oh, did your session work?
Yes.
Interesting. It does appear that the cubel is
working, but let me try and do this
in a way that we can share it
with people. So let me
try this one more time.
Oh, yeah. There we go. Alright. You can
join that session. Take it away. Let's call
it five more minutes, and then we'll we'll
wrap up. So use the hands of Nizit.
Have a look at the flags past the
kubelet. Maybe it's just got the wrong IP
or something like that
since it was running.
Wrong session. Which session is the right session?
A few seconds ago.
That's the right one. That's the one?
Alright.
Interesting.
Why is it trying to register itself as
Talos worker one?
You have an idea?
How we start? The kubelet.
Sorry. What? I heard two things at once.
Sean McCart suggested just restarting the kubelet.
Who actually takes thought service? Who's that?
Me. Alright?
Just because.
At least you don't grab the whole thing
first and then get the name and run
it. It looks good. People do that.
Alright.
I'm gonna switch back to
The node is ready now.
Alright. We are back on the control plan.
What is the pod pending if you describe
the pod?
That's the one we added the node selector
to, which may or may not work. Actually.
Are you at
Down.
Sneaky change there from Thanos. Sean is saying
they changed the host name, restarted the Coupa,
and then changed the host name back.
Oh my god. That's so cool.
That is nice.
Alright. Now, Ion, why don't you start?
Yeah. Describe the pod.
Container.
So whenever I see sandbox,
you wanna check the silly and pods are
scheduled.
I'm seeing invalid capacity zero on image file
system
in the events.
That's on Telus worker one as well.
Oh, and Telus worker one. Look at capacity
and items. Is that what's going on here?
Have we really gone this far?
Alright. We're gonna have to start wrapping things
up because I do have to do daddy
bedtime, I'm afraid. So why don't we why
don't we look at these hints? Like, Sean
is saying, let's burn the hints. So let's
work let's work our way through. So
five, let's turn it off and on again.
That must be the criblet. Six, it's not
C and I. There's no way it's C
and I. It is C and I. Definitely
a selam issue.
Alright. There's your hint. And ops, c and
I bend, there are lots of fails.
Running look back gives an output that's wild.
Well, let's go take a look at ops,
c and I bend on a worker.
We will do it on worker two.
Opt
c and I bin.
Am I dumb? I'm probably an LS?
Yeah.
Oh, there's a loop back
dot back.
So the original loopback is a bridge plugin
and then the loopback is a loopback plugin.
Oh, yeah. And also,
I mean, that was quite brave, not even
running them, just going for it. But
sure. I yeah. I I yell at them,
definitely.
Alright. Let's see if we can get our
pod scheduled then.
You
may have to delete
the Cilium pods. Alright.
Don't know if you'd have to delete the
Cilium pod. I'm not sure to be honest,
but you definitely need to delete the clustered
one.
We can default.
Oh, it's running.
It already finished.
Yep.
You
Do we get a dance?
Let me
I don't think we have v two yet.
Alright.
And there are
oh, there are normal hints, so that potentially
may be the last
one. Oh, it depends where it's scheduled.
Okay.
Well, let's delete the pod, see it get
recreated, and then
Yeah. I know.
Oh,
try refreshing it, David. I I just loaded
the app on my side and that it
works. There we go.
Bravo, Talos. Bravo. Yeah. That was tough. Well
done. Well done.
Those were two very, very brutal clusters.
These are all terrible,
terrible people. I gotta say.
Aren't you happy? You're not the one fixing
them? I am very glad. I am not
the one. Like, the minute I seen it
was STD, I was like, I'm I'm glad
that's not me. Like, I I think that's
that's my my crux. I just can't deal
with the STD stuff. So
good perseverance,
good working through it. And I think we
I definitely learned a lot. I'm assuming everyone
else learned a lot there. But the snapshots
and the member lists and stuff like that.
Absolutely. Absolute evil.
I'm
not sure what's worse though. Removing executable on
the things and then removing some binaries or
etcd.
Both particularly harsh.
Alright.
Thank you, team Red Hat. Was it fun?
Did you enjoy it at least?
Thanks for having us.
Yeah. It was fun.
Alright.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Have a wonderful day. Thank you for joining
me, and I will speak to you all
soon, I'm sure. Thanks,
Dave.
To our audience, thank you. That was absolute
slog. That was very difficult. Thank you, Talos.
Thank you, Red Hat. Thank you to Teleport.
Remember, if you want a sponsor of the
show if you want to support our sponsor
of the show, Teleport, please visit rockwood.live/teleport.
Have a wonderful day. We will be back
next week with more custard. I will speak
to you all soon. Thanks a lot. Bye.